I love Fargo I have to bring that up
with you yes I believe you're in when do
you start filming the fourth season is
it filming no we started on October 15th
and is that the kind of show where you
have most of the scripts done or how
does that because I've heard like with
Game of Thrones they at all 10 scripts
yes with Fargo how much are the scripts
done before filming begins and how much
is it sort of like you have the whole
thing really figure it out
but we only have like 5 scripts the
latter the you know it depends year to
year the first year I had 8 out of 10
the second year I had probably 6 out of
10 you know this year I'm in the 5 in
the 5 range you know some of it is just
one thing to another thing to another
thing you know and then I I took a
vacation because I think I deserved a
vacation I agree yeah and then I came
back and and you know I'm directing the
first block so you know in a perfect
world I would be writing scripts but
instead I'm prepping the show but you
know we mapped everything out I you know
I know the journey and and the writing
process for me is it's not a belaboured
lengthy one so I'm not worried about it
yet I understand I already have to go
but is there anything you can tease
about the season well the cast's is
incredible and and I would say it's
twice at least twice the size of any
other story that we've told both
financially and and you know just the
scope of it and the scale of it and the
period of it you know it's you know
there's no reason to do this again
unless I think it can be the best one
yet and I I think that